- [Narrator] Police in Maine
are on the hunt for an armed
and dangerous suspect
connected to two shootings
that officials say, killed
18 people Wednesday night.
The massacre in Lewiston,
Maine's second largest city,
marked the country's deadliest
mass shooting in 2023 so far,
according to the research
group, Gun Violence Archive.
Here's how the two shootings
that sent shockwaves through
the rural state unfolded.
At 6:56 PM on Wednesday,
police said they received
a call of a male shooter
at the Just-In-Time
Recreation bowling alley
in Lewiston, Maine.
Shortly after, at 7:08 PM,
police said they received
additional calls of an active shooter
at a restaurant called Schemengees,
roughly four miles away
from the bowling alley.
Around 8:00 PM, authorities
released images on Facebook
of the suspected shooter.
Maine State Police
issued a shelter-in-place
for local residents, urging them to stay
inside their homes with doors locked.
State police later identified
40-year-old Robert Card
of Bowdoin Maine as the
sole person of interest
in the shootings.
Around 10:00 PM, State Police
said in a social media post
that authorities located
a vehicle belonging
to Card at a nearby boat launch in Lisbon.
- Police are currently
searching for a Robert R. Card,
4-4-1983 of Bowdoin.
Card is considered armed and dangerous.
- [Narrator] On Thursday,
residents in Lewiston
and nearby towns were
told to shelter-in-place
as officers searched for Card.
Police confirmed that
seven people were killed
at Just-In-Time Recreation,
and eight people were
killed at Schemengees.
Three people later died in the hospital.
A White House spokesperson
said, President Biden
has been briefed and would
continue to receive updates.
- This city did not deserve
this terrible assault
on its citizens, on its peace of mind,
on its sense of security.
(sober music)